that the risk of war
in the oec area is now greater
than ever before
in the last 30 years
that's a stark warning there from
poland's foreign minister who also
chairs the 57-member osce the
organization for security and
cooperation in europe his comments
follow a series of talks this week
between russia and western diplomats on
tensions over ukraine
european union foreign and defense
ministers held their own meeting on
russia today the eu held no direct talks
with the kremlin this week but its
foreign policy chief denies that europe
is being left out of negotiations
especially with the threat of war in its
own backyard
we are in close cooperation and we are
assured that nothing will be decided nor
even negotiated with the russians
without a close coordination with europe
and without the participation of
europeans
so after a week of high level talks
between russia and the west we are clear
on two things non-starters and red lines
if the security of europe is facing its
greatest threat in 30 years what can
what will nato be able to do about it
dwe's brussels correspondent terry
schultz asks the man at the center of
this week's negotiations nato chief jens
stoltenberg
thank you very much mr secretary general
for making time for us today
so i wanted to start off with um
an assessment by putin spokesman dmitry
peskov just in the last couple of hours
that said the talks here were
unsuccessful now that's not necessarily
a bad thing for nato given what the
russians hoped to accomplish dividing
allies getting promises not to expand
things like that but what would be your
assessment of how the council went
yesterday i think it was an important
meeting
because just the fact that 30 nato
allies were able to sit down with russia
after two years with no meeting and
meetings in network share council was
important the discussions they were very
difficult we were there for four hours
but the fact that we had difficult
discussions actually for me just proves
the importance of the meeting
because we are faced with a very
critical uh
time for european security and uh i
believe that it's important to sit down
and address those issues we listened to
the russian concern we presented our
positions we are ready to engage in
dialogue russia but we'll never
compromise on core principles for
european security have you heard
anything back from them yet i i mean
it's only been 24 hours but did you when
you said that you you offered them a
series of talks about things other than
ukraine um issues of mutual concern for
the alliance and for russia would you be
willing to go into those talks without
discussing ukraine um would those be
completely irrelevant of whether there's
any progress or even any discussion on
the de-escalation over ukraine ukraine
will be part of those discussions as we
list the long range of different topics
we could discuss which are important for
european security
but for instance also arms control
limitations on the number of missiles
but this has to be reciprocal balanced
and very viable
measures to increase transparency on
military activities uh
risk reduction many other issues
and and we believe there is scope to
actually find solutions in some of these
areas but to do so we need preparations
we need to meet and we need a
good faith uh uh in addressing uh the
substance and and russia was not in a
position and i in a way i didn't expect
that either but they were not in
position yesterday in a meeting to say
we are ready to engage
but we
offer that possibility and then
they have to go back to moscow consult
and then you will get an answer for them
later on but again would they have to
discuss ukraine as well in connection
with this i mean we know that ukraine
has to be on the agenda of every
nato-russia council since 2014. if they
were not willing to de-escalate we're
not willing to take those steps would
you also be willing to enter discussions
on other subjects but but this is very
much intertwined i mean as long as soon
as we discuss european security and as
soon as we discuss risk reduction
transparency of course ukraine will be
part of those those discussions but i
think the best way now is not to conduct
diplomacy in
in media in the public it is to express
a willingness as we did in the meeting
yesterday to address a wide range of
issues uh we we stayed a ready
proposals on the table concrete
proposals on the table ready to listen
to their concerns and not ready to
compromise some core principles but
there are many other issues to discuss
and then if they reduce it done let's
sit down and then
in the meetings not in the media
start the negotiations and the talks did
the russians ask for this to be in
writing is that one of the things that
may be holding up a response we are
ready also to provide uh proposals
in writing and we have made that clear
and then there are different formats uh
of course some of these issues can be
discussed in the nato-russia council all
the issues may be negotiated bilateral
united states uh russia and we have the
strategic talks on nuclear issues
um and then we had the oc as another
forum and then we have normandy format
with germany and france is very engaged
and i would like to commend france and
germany what they do in the norman
reformer for that many different
platforms that we can address different
issues but i think the nato russia
council is important in a way to
coordinate to allies to convey a clear
united message from nato allies to to
russia and also to identify different
issues where we can work and address and
sit down and and see if we can find a
political way forward do you think
allies were satisfied with the u.s
russian bilateral talks um we're hearing
that the u.s may have brought up some
repositioning of forces in europe during
those talks and not everybody's
comfortable with that well the united
states has made very very clear that
those meetings were not negotiations
they were actually only the same as we
did here in brussels uh in the
literature council we we floated ideas
we were looking for ways and and topics
and and and and ways to organize a
process that can ensure a political uh
way forward
what we welcome is the very close
consultation between the united states
and european allies they consulted
before the meeting in geneva with russia
they consulted afterwards
and and some people have also you know
whether europe is at the table well
europe is at the table uh uh yesterday
in the meeting with the nato in the nato
russia council we had 30 you know 28
allies uh
european allies at the table so europe
is at the table that's what makes
nato unique it brings europe and north
america together also when you engage
with russia
as many times as you say that um russia
should not have a veto over certainly
expansion but other things doesn't it
feel like we are all at this moment
sitting waiting for president putin to
decide if he wants to go ahead with
talks he still does to some extent have
a say over what everyone else is doing
what the alliance is doing of course
russia decides what they do and they
have a choice either to engage in
dialogue
uh
with nato uh and uh western allies uh or
uh confrontation uh therefore we need to
be clear-eyed about the prospects of uh
that we will not have dialogue but
actually that russia once again will use
military force against ukraine but then
we have stated clearly that there will
be severe consequences for ukraine heavy
economic sanctions we will provide
support to ukraine we to also enable
them to strengthen their ability to
defend themselves and nato allies will
of course do what is necessary to make
sure that we have the necessary forces
in eastern part alliance to put to to
defend but also deter against any
aggression against the nato allies uh
deputy foreign minister khrushchev said
in his press conference after the
meeting that um russia has no troops in
the donbas is that your assessment as
well
russia controls uh the the separatists
in donbas and uh and and
through them they have presence in the
eastern part of
of ukraine there's no doubt about that
at this very moment military chiefs are
meeting and one of their priorities is
to discuss what can and should be done
in case of an incursion in case russia
goes further and perhaps even in case
russia just continues to keep the
tension level as it is right now which
is also you know untenable for for um
for many countries um
so do you feel like after this meeting
the likelihood that russia would step
over that line is is less because of
these talks and um what do you think of
suggestions that some allies may
pre-position more equipment in ukraine
as a sort of trip wire in case that
happened so that you would be more
prepared even though everyone knows
ukraine is not an ally nato has plans in
place for many different uh
contingencies and of course nato can
always
protect and defend uh all allies and
also deter an aggression against allies
ukraine is a partner it's not covered by
our collective defense clause article 5
but allies provide support
some of that support is provided through
nato
capacity building trust funds and so on
but also a lot of that support is
provided by lottery from different
allies united states united kingdom
canada and others and i welcome that
but at the end of the day this is of
course helping ukraine to defend
themselves and that's important because
it sends also a clear message to russia
and is that invasion less likely today
than it was yesterday i think it's too
early to to to to assess the outcome of
this meeting because we are not seeing
the response from russia
yet but i think the most important thing
is that we need to continue the dual
track approach russia we are ready to
dialogue we demonstrated that yesterday
but also prepared
if russia once again starts to use
military force against the neighbor all
right that's all my time thank you very
much
thank you
you